hi everyone Seth McFarland here and I am
thrilled to share the trailer for our
new peacock original series Ted telling
the story of Ted and John's early days
let's take a
look hey
Johnny how bad is school going to suck
you're not going to like it how bad well
it's like getting your nuts smashed
together so hard they become just one
nut holy
[__] you should be going to school every
day with John no thanks you might have
fun no I would not have fun I gu the
house when you guys are
[Music]
out what happened to the TV it was an
accident you're going to school and
you're going to grow a [__] brain oh
come
on hey DG you bringing your dolls to
school it's the '90s times are
changing sexual education let's start
with masturbation if you're going to
assign homework Johnny already did it
this morning shut the [__] up
dude I haven't smoked I haven't had sex
I had a girlfriend I'm going to lose it
you and me have been best friends like
our whole lives we're about to get high
for the first time can we have drugs
please let's do this
right oh
man can you guys believe we're like
having an experience and experiencing
reality is there a [__] gas leak or
something nice costume F face it's
possible that the two of you might not
be total
screwups take a long look this is what
life
is [__] Teddy I'm the last virgin in
school we can fix this we got to find a
fire fresh penis get your fresh penis
here Teddy Jesus Christ still has that
new penis smell you shut up all right
I'm just trying to
[Music]
help
that